bonjour à toutes et à tous
je suis ici pour vous parler de l'avenir
de la consommation collaborative
ce matin je me suis réveillée et j'ai
enfilé cette petite chemise
vous la voyez je les troquets sûr prête
à changer ensuite il ya une nana qui est
venu toquer à ma porte et à la loi ma
perceuse et avec l'argent que j'ai gagné
en louant cette perceuse j'ai pu prendre
un beurre pop pour aller au boulot pas
mal hein oui parce que ce que j'ai
oublié de vous dire c'est qu'en fait je
loue ma voiture tous les jours sur drive
vie et que du coup j'ai plus aucun moyen
de transport pour aller au travail et à
la fin de ma journée de boulot
moi je vais pas dormir chez moi non je
vais dormir chez mon mec parce que ça me
permet de louer mon appartement sur
airbnb oui oui vous l'avez compris je
suis une accro à la conso collab et
c'est pas pour rien parce que en un jour
avec ça moi j'ai gagné trois cents euros
je sais pas pour vous mais moi ce tarif
là j'arrête de vauseyon on est habitués
à connaître des entreprises qui vendent
aux entreprises et c'est ce qu'on
appelle le be to be on est habitués à
connaître des entreprises qui vendent
aux particuliers et c'est ça qu'on
appelle le bitoux si maintenant les
particuliers vendent directement en
particulier ça s'appelle la consommation
collaborative pour les intimes le site
ou si le terme de consommation
collaborative est né en 2007 et
maintenant mais ça cartonne tous les
français en parlent
on a quand même 65 % des français qui
disent consommer collaboratif
régulièrement et les chiffres des
plateformes à succès qu'on connaît tous
dans la consommation collaborative
blabla caroux airbnb par exemple le
prouve un service comme la blaquart
aujourd'hui en terme de trafic ça vaut
un cinquième de la sncf
si on vient au modèle de base finalement
c'est assez logique si je propose mes
services à blaquart et que je conduis
accompagné de trois autres personnes va
finalement ça a coûté quatre fois moins
cher c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
pour airbnb en sept ans airbnb en termes
d'offres avec 800 mes jambes c'est quand
même devenu le premier
repos teillé mondiale là il dépasse
intercontinental hotels group
il dépasse marriott hilton se fait
carrément pipi dessus en le regardant
airbnb oui mais moi si je suis au dessus
airbnb c'est quand même pas mal parce
que sans rien faire je vais quand même
gagné 7540 de leurs parents sans rien
faire peut-être que j'exagère un peu je
suis d'accord je doit accueillir
motoriste est lui passé les clés et
pourquoi ça marche aussi bien auprès des
consommateurs pourquoi tous les
particuliers sont séduits par la
consommation collaborative
je passe une semaine à new york
soit je vais dormir dans un hôtel plutôt
classique soit on propose un petit loft
tout mignon en plein coeur de brooklyn
pour vivre l'expérience du new yorkaise
comme à la maison
et en plus c'est 30% moins cher à votre
avis je choisis quoi j'ai 28 ans et au
final les services d'une femme roche
d'une femme de chambre pardon et le room
service d'un hôtel j'en ai pas besoin
moi ce que j'ai envie de vivre c'est une
expérience sociale quelque chose de
différent j'ai envie de voyager
authentique et des services de
consommation collaborative ne me
permettent de vivre des expériences
sociales en rencontrant aux quatre coins
du monde
chez eux ou chez moi des étrangers et ça
ça me permet de s'enrichir
culturellement mais n'oublions pas
quelque chose
ses hôtes ou les détenteurs des biens de
la consommation collaborative ne font
pas ça bénévolement les business de
consommation collaborative repose sur
une chose le facteur financier ayant
monté de service dans la consommation
perd hâtives
je ne vais pas vous cacher que je reçois
souvent des coups de fil de mon
entourage et ces personnes me disent
mais mode
j'ai une idée de malades
est ce que tu crois que c'est hubert is
able numérisables vérifiables le papa
est ce qu'à partir du moment où une
offre alternative existe par rapport à
l'offre traditionnelle power pop l'offre
alternative la voiture de particulier
l'offre traditionnelle le taxi est ce
que à partir de ce moment là on peut se
dire qu'un business et cohérent et qu'il
a un sens dans le secteur de la
consommation collaborative mois si on
prend l'exemple des enterrements de vie
de jeune fille par exemple il ya les
services de chippendale professionnel
mon mec par exemple je ne m'en sers pas
tous les soirs
alors mesdames ouvrez grand vos oreilles
parce que je vais pas pour vous le
proposer tous les jours mais je vous le
propose demain soir pour la modique
somme de 100 euros l'heure c'est quand
même vachement moins cher que dylan le
chippendale professionnels pour revenir
un exemple plus concret je vais vous
parler mon expérience j'ai créé un
premier service qui s'appelle cook and
meet le airbnb de la restauration et qui
vous permet d'aller dîner partout dans
le monde
chez l'habitant mais les modèles de
consommation collaborative ont leurs
limites et on ne peut pas les décliner
comme ça ces modèles la repose sur du
gagnant gagnant
c'est un principe qu'il faut respecter
et quand on est haute
sur un service comme cook and meat et
qu'on se retrouve pas financièrement
quand on a passé des heures à cuisiner
et que finalement on ne gagne pas
d'argent
quand on se retrouve consommateurs et
que un service censé être un service
alternatif ne nous coûte pas enchères
alors on fait l'expérience
une fois mais on ne répète pas et ça ça
pose des sérieux problèmes en termes de
pérennité de business là c'était une
équation
désolé le service de consommation
collaborative a un sens uniquement à
partir du moment où cette équation est
validé le gain doit être assez élevé par
rapport à l'effort fourni
on a tous envie de créer le airbnb
numéro deux en sortant d'école on se
retrouve tous dans la situation on veut
créer l'entreprise qui cartonne et c'est
logique mais ça va être de plus en plus
compliqué de trouver de vraies idées
avec un vrai sens économique pertinent
dans le service de consommation
collaborative le site ici mais est ce
qu'il n'ya pas une nouvelle manière d'y
penser
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une manière de
mieux appréhender la consommation
collaborative
moi je pense que l'avenir de la
consommation collaborative
c'est le site ou bi imaginer que des
particuliers puissent vendre leurs
services directement à des entreprises
c'est avec cette idée que j'ai décidé de
créer snap event snap events est une
plateforme qui permet en fait de louer
des appartements de particuliers avec
des traiteurs des animations à
destination des entreprises pour créer
des événements on peut créer dans les
appartements qu'on a aujourd'hui des
lancements de produits des acteurs work
même des réunions professionnelles
pourquoi finalement le si le particulier
a toujours été associé à sociale et
pourquoi finalement l'entreprise a
toujours été associé à argent
l'entreprise qui n est qu en fait qu'un
ensemble de particuliers pourquoi pour
une fois on ne penserait pas
différemment et on se dirait que le si
le particulier lui a besoin de gagner sa
vie et que l'entreprise elle plus que
tout en tant qu'ensemble de particuliers
a besoin d'avoir une dimension plus
sociale et est censé sensibiliser pardon
à des services originaux avec des offres
diversifiées et
intéressant en termes de prix pour
revenir à mon idée de départ
aujourd'hui on connaît bien le 'b to b'
le bitoux si le site aussi mais on est
en train de rentrer dans une nouvelle
ère et cette toute nouvelle ère
s'appelle le 6 to be personne n'ira à
l'encontre de l'histoire
si tous les consommateurs veulent
consommer d'une manière personne ne les
empêchera de le faire merci à tous pour
votre attention